[Music]
if you do it
yeah
the cost
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie you may have
seen the bombs the James gun was
dropping about Guardians 3 on Twitter
last night about how it's going to be
the last movie with this Guardians
roster not necessarily the last movie
with these characters so obviously
there's this unresolved scene with
little Gamora inside the soul world to
the soul gem at the end of infinity war
they're gonna have to pay that off
during Avengers 4 so there's just a
couple easy ways that they can do that
then wrap up this Guardians roster in
cycle into something new in phase 5 with
that x-men IP so I'll try to explain
what's going on with the Disney deal -
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a new round of the
Infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a mark related
comment on the video or name a new
winner at the end of this so first
things first unresolved plot Gamora is
stuck inside the soul gem now she's
alive in there the ruse is clarified
that the little one version of Gamora is
actually just an aspect of her soul it's
not the actual Gamora herself so she
doesn't have gamora's memories it's just
a piece of her that Thanos is
interacting with I've already done a
couple videos explaining the mechanics
of how the soul stone works it's pretty
much the same deal as it is in the
comics it takes and collects Souls it
preserves life after death which is a
very important concept to Cumorah coming
back that means she's inside the soul
gem somewhere but obviously the way they
perceive that in the comics is a little
bit different it's like an actual
terrain that you walk around whereas
here it's more of a 2001 Space Odyssey
thing where it's just like this mental
construct meant to give fan of something
to interact with this isn't exactly what
it looks like inside the soul gem it's
like the end of 2001 Space Odyssey that
room doesn't exist it's just like a
mental projection meant to help him
perceive what's going on as he becomes
the Starchild that's why they're using
the music from 2001 Space Odyssey like
danos has crossed the barrier by using
all six gems so like he became a god of
the universe for a brief period when we
get to Avengers 4 you might see more
constructs like this inside the soul gem
as they address that but obviously
there's all those rumors about them
going to other realities grabbing gems
from those
and forming a gauntlet that way so just
be prepared for the Russos to take a
couple of left turns but there's only a
couple of people that have the knowledge
in the power to actually help get her
out of the soul world one of those
people is Doctor Strange
so without the Avengers completing
another gauntlet using that to get her
out Doctor Strange is probably their
best bet meaning that they would have to
D a sh some other people which would
require Infinity stones or another
Doctor Strange from one of the other
realities in the multiverse so important
things to remember but they get Gamora
out they go off to Guardians 3 there is
an implied time jump with Avengers for
like at least a couple years go by
that's why iron man supposedly looks a
little bit older in these pictures look
at his hair during infinity war then
look at his hair in these pictures it
just seems like some time goes by we get
to the end of Avengers for most of the
characters if not all the characters get
closure like Drax wants to get closure
for the death of his family they sort of
teed that up during infinity war but
they haven't paid that off it feels like
if Thanos's last movie is gonna be
Avengers 4 then that's the last
opportunity for Drax to get closure on
that the only other character that will
require closure with Thanos would be
Gamora for obvious reasons so they go on
to Guardians 3 they can use that movie
to give closure to all the rest of the
characters relationships so like you
have Gamora and star Lord you have
rocket and Groot
you have Groot finally becoming the
adult version of Groot they could
probably save that for guardians 3 then
finally star-lord finding closure with
his mother's death because he still has
not come back to earth yet they bring
him back from the ashes sometime during
Avengers 4 he there has to like just
make peace with that
during Avengers 4 or they save that for
the end of guardians 3 where he finally
comes home but he's a space based
character so it would be kind of weird
if he just suddenly started hanging out
on planet earth the whole time it feels
like he belongs in space but here's the
thing James Gunn said that they're
cycling the roster meaning that they
would do more Guardians films or more
films with guardians teams I'll explain
the difference in those two things but
he also implied that some of the
guardians characters from this roster
will continue on into other movies they
just won't be on the guardians of the
galaxy team
like a really good example is his rocket
and Groot games gun said that he's
really open to doing a spin-off film
he's always said that rocket is his
favorite Guardians character there's so
much that we don't know about them so I
think they definitely come back either
in their own spin-off movie or in
somebody else's movie Chris Pratt has
said many times that he will stick
around for as long as Kevin Feige and
James Gunn will have him he might just
pop up in other people's films we'll get
to the x-men of it all because there's a
whole universe of characters that are
technically x-men IP like the Shiar war
of kings all these big space-based
movies that star-lord would fit in
perfectly so there's plenty of places
that you could put Chris Pratt in future
Marvel movies that aren't necessarily
the guardians of the galaxy films beyond
Adam warlock
in guardians 3 they're really like four
different things they can do with the
guardians of the galaxy in terms of
franchise IP because it's a big
franchise for them so they're gonna want
to do more Guardians teams one the
really easy thing is that they just
cycle the roster in present day with
like Adam warlock and a couple other
characters they give them a movie they
call it guardians 4 and everything's
fine
- they could do the exact same thing
with that new team like Adam warlock
showing up but instead of giving them
their own solo movie the team just pops
up the way that star Hawks guardians
pops up during guardians - for a couple
scenes they didn't even call that team
the guardians even though they were the
guardians 3000 roster you have Eternals
you have all those other x-men movies
that I just mentioned those guardians
could pop up in those movies without
them doing another genuine guardians for
movie 3 they could actually bring back
star Hawks team in present day inside
someone else's movie and they just call
them the guardians but I think he'd be
proud knowing that we're back as a team
I miss you guys so much yes let's say we
still soo [ __ ] and for they do a version
of that team said in the past like oh
wow these used to be the guardians a
long time ago but they haven't been too
clear about space-based movies said in
the past like Captain America is a
really good example of a movie set in
the past in the MCU because it's world
war two they could do the same thing
with their space-based IP there's
nothing stopping them from setting a
movie this not in present day in fact
the Russos talking about Avengers force
said that don't treat the timeline like
everything's gonna be linear happening
one right after the other that's
probably them just bracing everyone for
a time jump when Avengers 4 picks up but
let me know in the comments James Gunn
says that this roster won't be guardians
after guardians 3 anymore what do you
want them to do with that franchise do
you want to add a warlock led team do
you want them to bring back star Hawks
team but I'll say congratulations to JC
Lego man you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message me so I
can get your contact details leave all
your Avengers Marvel video requests in
the comments below click here for that
Avengers 4 Kevin Feige teaser and click
here for all those new DC movie teasers
like Aquaman and Wonder Woman to thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]